I asked my AI assistant to help me
reserve a table at a popular restaurant.
Here's what it gave me.
Now, it's not wrong.
The phone number is there.
The hours are right.
It even knows the walk-in oyster bar at
the front.
The model did the real work, but look at
the outcome.
I have to do my research and work
towards actually booking the table.
Like, we've been here for a while.
Now, imagine if you were to build
something like this for your customers.
What would you want it to do?
Same answer, rendered like this instead.
A date, a time, a couple of taps, and
then you're done.
The agentic product you're building
already has all the tools to support
your customer's needs.
The only thing that you need to focus on
is the layer between the model and
something that a human can interact
with.
That layer is what I'm going to talk
about.
The models and agents are here to stay.
And we should learn how to make it
friendly to the humans.
Hello. Welcome to my talk. I'm Balaram
Das.
I have been building customer-facing
apps for over a decade.
And the past 6 years I've spent building
Amazon Lens.
Amazon Lens is our suite of camera
features powered by AI.
It enables you to shop using images,
screenshots, and barcodes to discover
visually similar products.
If you have Amazon app installed, I
encourage you to try.
This talk comes from my experience
building
customer-facing products that are in
millions and millions of mobile devices.
Um quick dis- disclaimer before I go
further.
I'm giving this talk on my own. The
opinions in this talk are mine and not
my employer's.
When you think of building UX for an
agentic AI, obviously ChatGPT comes into
mind.
How do you draw these cards? How do you
choose carousel versus list? How do you
craft this so the human can understand
and interact better?
When you attempt to build something like
this, you run into a wall.
There are problems that need to be
solved from the very early stages of
your system.
Is that experience going to be snappy or
slow?
Do we get all the information at first
or one thing at a time?
And how do you scale this for mobile
apps where versions and device
capabilities are fragmented?
Like if you notice, none of these
problems are due to the model itself.
The model does its job well.
Um these are delivery problems and they
live in between the model output and
what's on the screen.
That is the layer that decides whether
your product succeeds or not.
So uh for this delivery problem,
if if you had asked me about uh about
this layer 2 years ago,
I wouldn't have had a name for it.
I'd built a couple of AI features by
then and every single time
I solved this part from scratch.
A bespoke pattern shaped around
whatever system I was in.
Uh there was no shared vocabulary for
any of it.
What gets me is that this thing now has
a name.
Generative UI.
And there's an open spec for it.
ATUI from Google.
Instead of the agent handing you a raw
text or HTML,
it describes the UI as data.
A list of components and the client
renders them with its own native
widgets.
A problem I used to solve alone
is becoming something teams get to start
from.
And that's exactly what I'm excited to
dig into.
Um normal API returns data
and the client decides how to draw it.
Like your model is good at tool use,
coding, and even other complex tasks.
It can do UI, too.
And that is what the generator UI is
about. And it's it's a spectrum.
Uh Co-pilot Kit, a company that does
this primarily, lays out
in three rounds.
At the bottom,
we have control.
The model picks
a pre-built component like a product
card.
It never invents anything.
In the middle,
um declarative.
The model composes UI from a catalog.
Uh date field, a time field, or a submit
button.
Um that's where A2UI sits.
And at the top,
it's fully open-ended.
The model generates a novel UI on the
fly like MC PA apps.
The higher you go, the more your client
has to trust whatever the model hands
it.
Um most production mobile apps live in
the bottom two rounds because, you know,
that's where you stay safe.
And that's what we'll focus on.
Um adding to the complexity of UX
building,
um mobile apps play an important part.
Um on the web, if uh render breaks, you
know, you ship a fix and it's live in
minutes.
Uh mobile apps cannot do that. Like
you're looking at hundreds of millions
of installs and you don't control
uh when any of them update.
So, when a client meets a content type
it's never seen,
it doesn't gracefully degrade, it
crashes.
And it keeps crashing for days or weeks
um in hands of people who haven't
updated.
So, one rule holds everything that
follows for mobile clients. You cannot
meaningfully patch the client.
Um how does this system look when you
zoom out?
Um here's the whole simplified pipeline.
Um version aware context face that feeds
the model. Uh yes, that is context
engineering.
The model outputs typed UI intent. Uh
that flows through a BFF backend for
frontend.
And to a client render that draws it and
uh falls back safely when it cannot.
We'll break into three patterns.
Pattern one, the rendering contract.
Pattern two,
streaming. Um that's the flow in between
them.
Pattern three,
uh the BFF that sits in the middle.
Uh we'll take them one at a time
starting with the contract.
Um
the contract is all about making the
model be aware of what the client
capabilities are. You ensure it it stays
true to the client that the model is
trying to draw the UI for.
Um
what it ensures is that that the onus is
not on the client or the rendering layer
to infer
what to show by looking at the token
output.
Um you also maintain a repository of
version map with the capabilities. For
example, you introduced a new flight uh
card UI in version 2.0.
Uh make sure to surface it to the model
only from version 2.0 onwards.
Um
when you build the context.
The takeaway here is that the model is
going to choose the CX and you provide
the right information in its con-
context.
Um let's take a look at this example.
And this this is usually the hard part
of building the system.
This is the model facing half of the
contract.
And you don't want the model to send
back text. Like, you want it to stream
blocks of UI components.
Um a conversation block for what it says
in text
and a UI block for what what it wants
the client to render.
The contract even encodes layout rules.
In this example, one to three flights
a swipable carousel.
Four or more, a vertical list.
The model picks the intent.
And notice what the model never does. It
never invents a component.
It chooses from a fixed menu that you
provide to it.
Obviously, it won't be in the millions.
It would be a handful.
It turns out that
it gets significantly harder as you
scale your features to more surfaces.
I'll let you think about how to engineer
that context to make sure the model
succeeds in picking one.
So, that's the contract.
Now, let's move on to the streaming
part.
This was eye-opening to me when I first
encountered it.
Traditionally, apps make an API call and
wait for something to happen.
When LLMs are involved, this pattern
becomes ineffective
as often the latency is higher due to
the model themselves.
And on top of it, there are tons of
additional checks to ensure safety and
whatnot.
And we also introduce a new layer that
it's going to be a little bit complex to
do the dynamic UI.
Um streaming helps here
uh by not making the client wait for the
whole response.
It renders things in chunks at a time.
Take a look at the illustrative example
when you have to surface information one
chunk at a time.
First, you show a skeleton, then
partially fill it, then complete it. It
may take 3 to 4 seconds
to get there, but the wait is bearable.
That kind of changes what you measure
for an app. Like you stop chasing the
total latency, which we have done for
over a decade.
You start chasing
time to first chunk. You know, the first
useful thing that your user sees.
For this reason, the traditional loading
spinner won't work for AI features.
Sometimes,
you have to get creative and design your
feature around it. This may not work for
all, but here's a product example. And
when you know it's going to take time to
render something, keep the user engaged.
The Lens live allows the user to focus
different things, um tap on an object
that they're interested in while they
wait for the results.
Uh if you don't have the full screen in
your control, you can show the thinking
CX. But please use it sparingly. The
overall AI users have moved out of the
forgiving phase, and now they expect to
know what is happening.
Now that you have a way to stream back
different states, you know how to show
what your agent is doing.
Um here's an example I copied from
Gemini.
When when it starts to work on a task,
it gives a glimpse into what the agent
is doing.
Even though it takes 10 seconds, I'm
okay if I know what's happening and
be able to trust the agent's final
output.
We have covered streaming.
Let's move on to the final and most
important part.
Your new BFF.
Pattern one was about how UI gets
picked. Pattern two was about how the
chunks delivered.
Pattern three is all about how the
chunks become meaningful UI elements.
This is a concept of server-driven UI.
And it's a spectrum of server control.
And the more the server controls, the
more you build.
The BFF is a subset of it and decides
how to render.
It owns the platform specific rules like
Android versus iOS, that kind of stuff.
Uh it also helps the client to make less
decisions and draw what's handed to it.
That's the whole idea.
The BF BFF doesn't just ship layout.
It does a little more.
In addition to the format and context,
it does the hydration and adds actions.
Every rendered element carries an action
payload to handle what
what a tap does, what the deep link hit
opens.
It could even name the impression metric
to log.
It carries this conversational context
across turns. So, the next response know
what came before.
And the good thing about this is that
you can actually do this to your
existing apps.
You can reuse the existing CX units you
already have.
The flight row, the product card, the
components your app already shipped in
production.
You're not building a new agentic look
into your app. And that's a good way to
build for humans.
Same brand, same density, same familiar
feel.
It looks and feels native.
That brings to our takeaways.
One, the models are highly capable
already.
You feed a properly typed, versioned
contract so it can pick and choose the
right CX.
Two,
stream into typed components, not text.
Let the user know what your agent is
doing.
Three,
let the BFF absorb the model output so
the client can stay dumb and safe.
No, none of these are about the model.
The model was fine.
This layer is what ships the product.
Bringing back to where we started,
your agent output is not the CX. You
build on it.
Thanks for watching.
If you'd like to learn more or connect
with me, here's a QR code.